All right. Yeah. This is it folks. This is COVID. We're doing it.
We're in a hotel right now. Somebody above us is, yeah.
That's kind of fun to think about. Uh, and I have, Hey folks,
here we are in Hasbrouck Heights, New Jersey, sin city,
baby. We're doing bananas comedy club. Hey,
they know comedy here, sunglasses on a banana. That's the height of humor.
So, uh, let's get in there. Here I am. And the holiday Inn.
Oh yeah. Don't worry. Last week I was in a red roof. So this is a step up.
It's a nice place. You know, the chandelier's looked like, ah,
yes, this is quite the, a locale. Huh?
Here I am on a couple of coffins and uh, standing in front of a,
I think this is like an impeachment curtain. Yeah. Sorry. I didn't know.
She was an intern. All right.
This is a nice touch. The light up sign. We don't have to buy a sign.
We'll just put a projector up. But thanks for coming.
I appreciate it. You know, we're indoors. Spooky.
I might die. Uh, but at least we went out with a bang, right, sir? Yes.
You look. All right. I'll pick it up. Just got up here.
But I will say this we're all adults here, but you wouldn't. How old are you?
Yeah. Oh, we're not all adults here, but uh,
all right. Sorry, but I didn't mean out you there, but Jesus Christ 16.
No wonder. I'm hard. Yeah. Holy hell.
The hell's going on over here. And is this your brother? Oh, thank God.
I hope it was. I thought it was your date. Um,
all right. Well you're, you're fun brother.
Taking your little brother up there to hear about and black people.
You're a you're 18. Oh, you're 21. Okay.
Well then you're a nerd hanging out with that kid. What the hell? You know what?
Thanks a lot. I'm sure you guys are great. Thanks for coming out. Ah, Ooh.
That was a tough group, man. Did I die up there? We've got one more show.
Now we're gonna hit the diner. Ooh.
Oh boy. Comedy, baby pandemic. Yeah.
I think we got to clean this room out after for a bar mitzvah. It's coming in.
Yeah. Oh boy. Oh boy. This is really the height of humor. Isn't it?
This is a career peak for me. I love the spacing.
It looks like you guys were all at each other. This looks like a funeral order.
Nobody I'll be like the guy who died, but you got a good chuckle, sir.
And I can tell you have a pretty decent penis.
Look at the arms on that guy. What? He is six, two, six,
seven. Get the out of. Holy hell.
One of those buckets. Was that just food for you? You're just feeding you.
Put it around your neck, like a horse. Six, seven.
Is it weird if I asked you to stand up? All right.
I'm sure you get it all the time. Oh wow. Yeah. There you go.
All right. Yeah. Don't applaud him. Applaud his mom's broken vagina.
Jesus, grace. How that helps you push that thing out? Oh my God.
That is quite a canal. Well thank you, sir. And, uh,
ma'am, you're a hell of a trooper. Holy Jesus.
Good. God, you should be on top. Um,
I'm sure you're off the ground a lot of times. Uh, anybody,
uh, it's all over the map here.
That would be something that's wonder. I was like, it up. I'm six, nine. Oh,
well you do have to fight to the death. Three boys.
They're all yours. Oh, then you combine.
[Inaudible].
Oh wow. We're learning a lot here.
You got to give her a little girl. Good dog.
Everybody staying in the hotel.
We got to all get a room and just the word Jade up. I got an idea.
I'll spring for the room, but you know,
somebody is going to put a baby girl in earth. Thank you. I love you Jersey.
Get on say Hey, great show folks. Second show is killer.
I feel reborn at first show is in the gutter. Now I'm back, baby.
It's amazing. What a hot crowd can do. So thanks for coming out, Jersey.
We'll see it. The next spot on the road every weekend.
Let's go get the diner and a limit up milkshakes on me.
Thanks guys. I'll call ya. There you go.
Sweep it up.